i
was born in 1872
my parents died when i was still in
infant
and so i was brought up by my
grandparents
can you tell us something about your
grandfather
yes i could tell you something about my
grandfather
he was born
in the early years of the french
revolution
he was a member of parliament while
napoleon was still on the throne
[Music]
in common with all the
greek followers of fox
he thought english hostility to napoleon
was excessive
[Music]
it was he who introduced the reform bill
in 1832 which started england on the
road towards
democracy he was prime minister during
your mexican war
during the revolutions of 1848
i remember him quite well
but as you can see he belonged to an age
that now seems rather removed
and
[Music]
in the world where i was young
was a solid world
a world where all kinds of things that
have now disappeared were thought to be
going to last forever didn't dawn on
people's things
see
english people certainly regarded
english naval supremacy as a sort of law
of nature britannia ruled the waves it
indeed occurred to us that that might
stop
everything even with bismarck
bismarck misregarded his
rascal
and
we thought i was a sort of uneducated
farmer
but it was assumed that the influence of
gertie and schindler would gradually
bring germany back to a more civilized
point of view
and moreover
we thought of germany as only a land
power germany had at that time known
navy
we weren't all afraid of germany in fact
liberal opinion was more favorable to
germany than to france at that time
the german bismarck himself
compared germany and england to an
elephant and a whale each formidable in
its own element but no danger to each
other
and that was how we felt so we were not
afraid of bismarck at all
it was thought that there was going to
be ordered progress throughout the world
gradually every country was going to
take departments there was going to be
a bicameral legislature and two parties
and it will all go to be exactly like
everywhere all over the world
my grandmother used to laugh because one
time she said to the russian ambassador
perhaps someday you will have a
parliament in russia only god forbid my
dear lady russell
except for the first word the russian
ambassador at the present day might give
the same answer
but
that was the assumption it was all going
to be orderly all quite nice
the
atmosphere
apart from politics there was one of
puritan piety
very great party very great austerity
we always had family prayers at eight
and before family prayers i had to do
half an hour's practice at the piano
which i hated
although there were eight servants in
the house
the food was always the utmost
simplicity
and
even if what there was if there was
anything at all nice i wasn't allowed to
have it because it wasn't good for
children to eat nice things
for instance there would be rice pudding
and apple tart
don't upset the apricot and i had the
rice pudding
and there was extreme austerity in all
those ways
my grandmother until she was over 70
would never sit in an armchair until
after dinner
ever
[Music]